[Musique]
alors comme ça moi y'a des gens qui me
ressemblent mois battu à voir toi tu vas
voir toi lui rien ne va dans les baux de
squeeze et vous savez que cet ego est
énorme
je reçois depuis quelques temps de plus
en plus de tweets qui disent et regarde
les trois centres on dirait un sourire
ça te fait rire tu sais ce que ça fait
de se sentir plus uniques sur cette
planète
un des amis aujourd'hui j'en ai marre de
ne plus sentir unique de me dire que
d'autres gens sont très très proches de
moi physiquement ça me dérange
alors on va regarder un peu tous ces
gens là qui me ressemble ou alors c'est
moi qui leur ressort pour sais pas
d'ailleurs et on va trouver l'élu celui
qui me ressemble comme deux gouttes
d'eau que ma mère pourrait confondre
avec moi même pour ce faire clément a
mis au point un algorithme ou un effet
au montage on sait pas ce que c'est non
c'est pas si c'est réel ou avait fait du
montage qui nous donnera un peu le
pourcentage de ressemblance et je vous
le dis je vous l'assuré
d'ici la fin de la vidéo on aura trouvé
qui me ressemble le plus de tout
internet et s'il y en a qui me ressemble
vraiment beaucoup je contacterai pour
voir s'il peut pas venir ici au studio
et je lui parlais etc pour créer du
contenu pour vous divertir et à la fin
je débuterai comme ça je reviendrais
unique c'est bon et jeté des mois tout
excité mais c'est vrai que ça me
travaille un peu pour de vrai cette
histoire c'est parti ça commence ici
avec le monde à l'envers qui me dit
désolé j'espère que vous êtes désolé
c'est horrible le plus gros point commun
que j'ai avec cet homme c'est un petit
défaut la calvitie algues aurait dit
nous la vérité sur 7
j'ai craché
34 % c'est pas dégueu c'est pas lu que
je rejette un truc c'est que si on fait
un photomontage de moi sur sa tête c'est
drôle elle est hôtesse main dans le
résultat
personne ne veut se marier cet homme je
trouve que antoine te ressemble beaucoup
sur certains angles surtout les yeux
alors attention le mot surtout est le
mot que ne sont pas les mêmes il ya
vraiment eu rayures au chip rencontre de
deux sosies
à part ça je l'avais vu passer mon gars
c'est fabuleux regardez que vont dire et
bigorneaux et coquillages mais dans une
autre dimension avec ces fous pas je ne
sais pas qui sont ces gens mais lancer
une chaîne youtube qui s'appelle bigand
de coquillages de il pourrait faire une
vidéo à notre place sur la chaîne bigand
de coquillages que personne ne verrait
rien sur la chaîne de big n dri
coquillages c'est un truc avec tommy
cash on mettrait ton visage ce serait
presque similaire ou pas je vois ce que
tu veux dire encore une fois le meilleur
moyen de savoir si on se ressemble c'est
de mettre mon visage à la place du sien
et de voir si ça nous trouve beaucoup
parfois je trouve alors on le fait
maintenant est alors non et en plus
c'est ça fait c'est rick rypien et non
pas ça la suite petite ressemblance vite
fait alors physiquement ou dans le
contenu alors lui je n'ai vu revenir
mille fois aussi je sais pas qui c'est
mon gars mec c'est vraiment un mix entre
janka et moi vrai ou faux
tiens j'ai trouvé ça sur une pub
instagram pour monoprix
c'est troublant la bizarre c'est comme
si c'était moi qui ai fait ça et je n'ai
pas de souvenir de l'avoir fait mexes
est troublant ça mais attend on va la
retrouver cette pub monoprix
[Musique]
thida aubry
[Applaudissements]
avant ils aient pu sceller un peu juste
il échoue
est ce je m'amuse la chasse aux sosies
je vous jure avant la vidéo est un sosie
qui vient squeeze alias drago malefoy
vraiment pas du tout j'aurais adoré être
là serpente avec ma baguette mais non ça
ne marche pas vraiment ça match pas du
tout alors ça aussi j'en ai marre je
suis là ça c'est ce qui m'a le plus
poussé à faire cette vidéo ce mec est
égérie pour une marque qui apparemment
fait des ciseaux et des découpes ongles
que plus stylée que d'autres cuisines et
du coup chaque abonné que j'ai quand il
passe à la pharmacie et qui voient ça il
le tout et me fait rêver c'est toi je
t'ai vu derrière une lime à ongles alors
j'ai aucun problème avec le fait qu'on
croit que je vais gérer pour des couples
mais je suis pas gêné pour des coupons
bloqués c'est pas moi
la barbe c'est bon mais c'est les
cheveux le problème donc je regarde
comme lui en mode vilain garçon
[Musique]
non c'est non [ __ ] une petite
ressemblance
[Musique]
bah ya un petit truc là même si sa barbe
est plus belle que la mienne
regardez en plus tout le monde c'est
génial c'est vraiment un truc qui le
suit doit me détester sur les toits
alexandre mon sosie officiel je mets
contacter alexandre ça trouve il me
déteste ou on eût dit tout le temps tu
ressens un squeeze ça le fait chier il n
aime un croisement vers moi il acheter
des posters de moi et ils jouent aux
fléchettes deuxième peut-être bref je
vais le contacter et si les chaudes en
quelques secondes nous avons traversé
cette porte pas sur le péno son frère
jumeau c'est parti alex merci d'être
venus mais pas tout de suite très moche
déshabille réputé la blague c'est quand
il est en bas et que je vais aller lui
dire bonjour quand je t'ai vu en bas et
souche ça m'a fait bizarre et communes
d' un truc bizarre entre niger après
avoir déjà vu alors moi je trouve qu'on
se sent beaucoup mieux est qu'on va
savoir si c'était mon sosie officiel
et pour ça on va faire un petit test
très simple je viens aux tweets et que
je vais sur mes gueule pour rencontrer
les gens
sauf qu'en fait c'est toi qui va être
ici à ma place et qui va dire bonjour
aux gens et on va voir combien de temps
ça va durer a rempli jean gris la
supercherie jeter prêté un t-shirt à moi
et je t'ai frétin casque et allemands
comme ça il ya vraiment tout pour que
les gens confondent mais [ __ ] tatouage
les tatouages en écho à tambour le tuc
ah ouais ça ça casse les tatous sinon
les baisers comme tu es dans mon école
et qu'en plus tu as un tee shirt que
j'ai mis dans des vidéos il ya tout pour
que les gens te confondre avec moi est
ce que ça va marcher on va voir
[Musique]
elle en a cédé mon sosie et a rien vu
t'as rien vu venir
c'est mon sosie à vous tapez a reconnu
qu'est ce que c'est mais si non merci
ici c'est mon petit souci avec des trucs
de ma vie
salut
[Musique]
bonjour aux eaux alors à l'eau julie
nous ça fait pas mon temps de chien
ouais j'ai une surprise et ça va c'est
moi squeeze je crois c'est un sosie
les gardes c'est alexandre était
présente à lyxor bonjour bonjour avec
toi mais mon dieu qu'est ce que tu as
une chaîne youtube moi ouais je file
berkouk et c'est quoi ton prénom
antoine alexandre est ce qu'on n'irait
pas s'abonner à la chaîne d'antoine macé
à les silver costume pour la petite pub
c'est pour toi c'est pour toi antoine
blague à part de mon pote la has et du
dessin il s'appelle big verdi trop et il
est hyper talentueux il mérite beaucoup
c'est bon niveau plus grande est bon
ouais c'est mon avis qu'ils m'ont aussi
parfait beau et bientôt
[Musique]
blige c'est avec ça c'est un sosie
non non j'ai bien cru n'en sais rien
bah oui on fait une blague mais là on
est vraiment là est ce que tu as cru que
c'était moi au début si oui au début
mais je vis mon dirais pas trop libre
d'hier et à l'eau
entend pas que tu fais mais maintenant
complet mais attend ses banques aux pays
où ce que tu as là c'est génial et les
parties sans la
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il ya mais paraît elle a
séparé le belge olivier marais à loisy
agréé on t'a vu totalement si oui non ça
c'est pas un fake bon mec
non c'est un vrai sourire hier je peux
le toucher brasles que j'ai l'âge où
s'associent ya pas son père mais il
croit que j'attaque [ __ ] alors oui
c'est nous cas bonjour aux punaises
j'ai cru que j'étais un sac banane on
n'y a pas que des fake ah ben il y en a
il y en a c'est ça le problème c'est pas
un fake c'est un sosie
non non non je n'étais pas le vrai
vainqueur avec teva littéralement 30
minutes que je te cherche à la patience
porte ses fruits car on ne sait pas moi
qui te parle en fait moi je
[Musique]
beau squeeze c'est terminé et j'ai envie
de faire un épisode de direct rendre les
gens ils sauveront après la soirée la
vidéo est en anglais
bon bah non je te fais un rêve de ciel
vous a plu ça y est j'ai trouvé ce sosie
attention l'instar de squeeze de sa
fiche ici ou non tu sais quoi en ce
moment j'ai la flemme de faire des
photos pour - star fait les photos de
toi tu me les envoie et je l'aimé dieu
benoît de souci je vais lancer les
scènes à moi m'a dit pas de problème
ok pas de souci c'est cool renouvelle
ses coupes c'est encore des petits
services entre sociaux et pas de souci
mon petit bain les amis je fais des gros
bisous merci alex c'était trop bien m
merci alex il a pris le train il m'a
répondu il a dit ok je prends le train
il est venu c'était son journée de ce
son jour de repos il est venu là où
j'aimerais faire un plissement pour alex
merci merci a bientot masse une
prochaine vidéo santé vous bien au
revoir et bonne chance pour tous
mercredi
[Musique]